well Hamilton does character good play
he's one of those guys that has a lot of
experience nice pass and a nice finished
with the offhand by DeAndre Jordan way
off the mark
there's dodge hits with his first touch
all the way to the rim coast-to-coast
for a look at dodging almost pushed me
out much there's no question about it
when you miss the jump shot you know
better than anyone where it's gonna come
off he was in the right place at the
right time yeah it almost pushed me out
much
quick outlet for Smith for three is no
good for Luther here with the Mavericks
right away because he passes the batter
anytime you looking to pass the
basketball really nice pass by Dennis
Smith but again Cleveland making himself
available there this left side of the
floor harp is not here on the right side
there you go Dennis Smith finds the open
bet old weak side and Maxie Cleave able
to finish it aware of that shot clock
just got it off dodge hits for three and
that looks sweet has made him the most
accomplished international player that
has ever come into the ditch with the
handle the control and everything that
has made him the most accomplished
international player that has ever come
in yet dodge it okay oh yeah we like
that off balance the sickness
SJ shake crossover to the hoop and
hoarding on another deficient pace my
Dennis Smith jr. for the finish his last
five games last year he went 8 of 15
from behind the line and again you know
there was so much going on a good
traffic rebound by dodge the advantage
inside deep 3 pretend to give the
Mavericks Smith junior how did he keep
his balance there and able to finish it
off the reverse the final points of a 16
before Mavericks rot over the last 4 29
in the first half to give the barracks
how did he keep his balance there and
finish
well this is pretty from George as good
as any one of the NBA's Derek and doing
that
that's a nice slip by chore to the rep
for the finish that's beautiful Smith
able to hit it and they really want him
to be able to do that
Smith long hesitation got the step and
it's gonna finish it all that's the
permission that time in your open court
cuz they know they're our first half
team guys you to fool lob there to
[Music]
Jordan see it developing right away
Jordan that time and dsj eventually
finds a wide open
crossover doctor just wide open he found
the blade and nobody's he reports head
and three that shot looks good
the crossover tachtsidis wide open he
found the blade and nobody's theorem for
its head in three
that shot looks good with back-to-back
threes able to set himself and fire
three of three from behind the line
tonight at a part of a 14-point night
Jordan has never been lower than third
in the last six years in dunks in the
NBA and Luca Dodge it's showing you've
got plenty of range on that
three-pointer and every 10 20 at
halftime it's a 20-point lead now as we
come down on three minutes to play in
the third the second block of the night
beautiful second slip with a picket wall
by the center and Duns it's both times
able to find